I'm not sure how long this
lecture is going to be.
We could be finished in 10
minutes though. I doubt that. Um,
and if we're not finished
at the end of the 50, um,
there is some things that I've reserved
for the end of the lecture that I
definitely do want to get said.
I don't know if you've noticed.
There are times when,
uh,
the last point or two that I appeared
to have been preparing to make,
never did get made,
but in this case,
I want to make sure that they are
made so that if I don't finish today,
uh, or if I still have a
point of tooth to make,
I'll definitely be taking up those points
at the beginning of Thursday's lecture.
All right, now, um,
the African American tradition of literary
production is rich and longstanding
as Henry Louis Gates tells
you, uh, the first, uh,
really rather important poet and the
tradition Phillis Wheatley is, uh, a,
an American colonial writer.
Uh,
the flourishing of the slave narrative
form begins in the 18th century,
continues into the 19th,
uh,
in the 19th century witnesses, uh,
extraordinary works of fiction.
And in the 20th century, of course, most
conspicuously in the Harlem Renaissance,
but throughout the century,
uh,
there has been a extraordinary work
done in the African American literary
tradition. It's a very rich
tradition. In other words, uh,
somewhat in contrast with the very
rich but also very recent tradition of
African American literary
theory and criticism,
it's possible to argue that
the development of theory
and criticism in this
tradition was somewhat
barked by a preliminary way
in which it found itself at
odds with itself.
Um,
black criticism and black feminist
criticism from the beginning saw that they
didn't have quite the same agenda.
This is something that can
resonate perhaps later in
this lecture when we moved
to other topics. Uh, but in the
meantime, critics like Barbara Christian,
Barbara Smith, Debra
McDowell, Hazel Carby,
bell hooks were in there
a variety of ways, uh,
working with emphases that, uh, other, uh,
and sort of typically male, uh,
African American critics, uh,
weren't quite comfortable with.
And so while a work,
especially beginning in the 80s, a
proliferated there was, as I say,
a kind of internal divide,
which has been a complex matter
to negotiate and which, uh,
is I think now largely a sort
of detente has been achieved.
Uh, and, uh,
African American literary theory is
moving forward unfettered any longer by
these concerns or at least, uh,
by any excess of these concerns.
But in the meantime,
that may partly account for a certain
delay and the emergence of theory and
criticism, uh, given the, uh, uh,
sort of longstanding richness
of the literary tradition.
Now the role of Henry Louis Gates in a
African American criticism is it seems to
me a exemplary,
although there are some rather harsh
moments in this essay moments that I,
that I, I wished to take up,
uh, that would suggest, uh,
an element of what shall I
say, extremism or overkill, uh,
in,
uh,
gates is thinking this is actually
not at all the persona that he has,
uh, projected. Uh, and indeed. Um,
what's extraordinary about
gates? Who's, who's, uh, uh,
administrative power, whose, whose
abilities as a program builder,
as we say,
are remarkable.
After he left Yale to go to Harvard,
he was able to gather to Harvard,
Anthony Appear,
Cornell West and others, uh, who
have since departed from Harvard. Um,
but gates is in a way an empire
unto himself. And, uh, he,
he has been an extraordinary figure.
The earliest work,
which is actually among
the earliest work is,
is what you've been reading for today.
Uh,
established his reputation
together with, um, a, the,
his discovery of not so much discovery
of but authentication of a manuscript by
Harriet Wilson, which he published
an important contribution,
uh, to 19th century, uh, uh, our,
our knowledge of 19th century
African American literature. Uh,
in any case, uh, what
happened then was that gates,
who's who by some miracle or an or other,
he was a perfectly good
writer in the first place,
but gradually became a marvelous writer,
began writing for the New Yorker,
and during this phase of
his, uh, of his career when,
among other things,
he produced a remarkable autobiography
about growing up in West Virginia.
Um,
during this phase,
Gates really became a
spokesperson for a detente among,
uh, races and racial
factions. In other words, uh,
he was a voice of moderation without
incurring any amputation of Uncle Tom Ism
or anything of the sort. Uh, his very,
his sheer urbanity as the
remarkable writer that he is,
uh, in those years when he
wrote under Tina Brown, uh,
for the New Yorker, uh, it was just a
remarkable achievement and his career, uh,
is still,
is still going strong now for gates as
for Elaine Showalter last week and for
Wolf before her,
uh,
the problems surrounding the,
the concept of identity
possessed identity, uh,
which of course is, um, uh,
an important anchor for the thinking of
people who feel the need for voices for
a place,
uh,
in the literary and cultural
horizon is nevertheless,
at least potentially as we've begun
to notice already a kind of quicksand.
Um, the problem that there are two
problems really that dog, uh, I,
the, the issue of identity. One of
them is the problem of essentializing,
which I'll take up now and
then as I'll take it up next.
Also the problem of what might
be called the identity queue. Uh,
in other words, I am a, um, a lower class,
a black lesbian feminist who's,
uh,
who's a nation is Palestine.
Uh,
needless to say, I have a variety
of identity options to choose from.
Uh, but the result is the result is
I've got to figure out which of them has
priority.
In other words,
which of those identities do I suppose is,
has the underlying,
uh,
integrity and essence,
sensuality,
uh, that can motivate, um, as it were,
the characteristics of
my other identities, uh,
at which are therefore somehow or another
placed, uh, further down the cute.
Uh, so this, uh, is, is, is a topic
that I'll come back to in a minute,
but in the meantime,
the problem of essentializing
as we say a as we call it,
um, for example, uh, uh,
as gates describes it on page 1893 in
the right hand column where he's very
clear on the dangers of ascribing whether
positively or negatively attributes to
any group that is constituted as,
or thought of.
Because of course,
the notion of race and whether there
is race is in itself according to gates
problematic. Um, the problem
of ascribing attributes, uh,
even unethically,
uh,
to erase race as he
describes it on page 1893,
the sense, the sense of difference
defined in popular usages.
Finally, finally, my voice is
changing. Uh, the set, the,
the sense of difference defined in popular
usages of the term race has been used
both to describe an inscribed
differences of language,
belief system,
artistic tradition,
gene pool and all sorts of supposedly
natural attributes such as rhythm,
athletic ability,
cerebration,
usury and fidelity and other words,
obviously a portioning out stereotypes
to the various groups that may come
forward as candidates to be racist.
And pointing out that all of these
stereotypes do nobody very much.
Good. Um, so the problem
of essential Ising which,
which under girds they wish to make
manifest the existence of race because,
because, think about
it. On the other hand,
Gates seems to be divided
in the beginning of,
as of his essay between a certain
candor about race as in the work of
[inaudible] 10 that he
describes in which race, uh,
[inaudible] a and cultural moment are
considered the key determining issues of
any kind of artistic or cultural
production. He says, well,
at least race is being talked about
while at the same time obviously wincing
away from the implications of race and
from the belief that there is such a
thing as rice, which goes all the way
back to Montesquieu and others, uh,
in 10.
Nevertheless,
he's rather cheerful about the fact that
at least race is being discussed unlike
the 20th century when the whole thing
is swept under the rug. Uh, and, uh,
kind of birth sites and hypocritical
politeness prevents anybody from talking
about such categories at all.
Uh,
and gives rise to the idea that we
all exist in the same great tradition.
Uh, that work either belongs to that
tradition or if it for some reason seems
egregious or outside the tradition,
it just can be shoved aside and neglected.
That's the supposition of the 20th
Century When folks don't talk about race.
And so, you know, the very
questioned whether it is an issue,
uh, is part of this
problem that is dogged, uh,
by the more complicated, uh, the
issue of a centralized for example,
suppose as, and of course you've
been reading about this and in,
in show Walter as well,
suppose you ascribe positive value
to what another person might call a
stereotype. This is
what, uh, the, uh, the,
the important a francophone African poets
Song Gar does a as gates says at the
top of page 1901 the right
hand column Gates says,
when we attempt to appropriate by
inversion race as a term for an essence,
as did the negritude movement,
for example,
we feel therefore we are a song Gar
argued of the African we yield too much,
such as the basis of a shared humanity.
Such gestures as Anthony of
Pia has observed are futile
and dangerous because of
their further inscription of
new and bizarre stereotypes.
So you can see there are a lot of land
mines to be avoided and negotiating the
discourse of race. Uh, and certainly, uh,
certainly gates is aware of them.
Now,
there's also the problem,
as I say,
of the identity Q and Gates himself
may have a little difficulty with this,
at least from time to time because
as I said at the beginning,
he does have this sort of uneasy detente
with feminism in the African American,
uh, critical tradition, uh, still
to work within. And so exact,
for example, on page 1894, um, uh,
somewhat problematic passage in
which the identity queue, uh,
seems to be at issue about a third
of the way down the left hand column,
he says,
the sanction of biology contained
in sexual difference simply put,
does not,
and can never obtain when one is
speaking of racial difference.
Yet,
we carelessly used language in such a
way as to will this sense of natural
difference into our formulations.
So what he's saying is in biological term,
there's definitely a difference between
the sexes, but in biological terms, uh,
there is not necessarily a
difference among, uh, the, uh,
so called primary races.
So that,
so that at least when one speaks of
women and men in the feminist tradition,
one has to come face to face with it,
with the problem of actual difference.
Whereas one,
one speaks of black and white in the
traditions of discourse about race.
One isn't actually talking about a
genuine difference at all and their
[inaudible] and the
therefore, uh, the, uh,
the discourse with the greater integrity
of the two as the one which is about
differences that are absolutely a femoral
as opposed to the one which is about
differences,
which whatever one thinks of them and
whatever one wants to make out of them are
nevertheless essential. Now, plainly,
when we go back to feminist criticism,
particularly the,
the gender theory of Judith Butler,
we'll see of course,
that the whole question of the
biological basis of sex, uh,
the biological, uh, difference
between the sexes, uh,
which essential AISES.
Uh,
what we will be wanting to
talk about is of course,
something that is profoundly in question
and not just because of so-called
transgender transgender issues,
but also at the same time,
uh, because of the way in which, uh,
are very sexual identity is something
which according to Butler we construct.
And so there is,
um,
an insistence here on biological
difference between these two forms of
discussing identity,
which may or may not seem
to us to be problematic.
Now, I think this is the point at
which we can see the importance,
uh,
the extraordinary essay that I've also
asked you to read by Tony Morrison.
You know,
her best of course as a novelist,
but she's also a distinguished critic
as she has been a distinguished editor,
uh, of, of, of, of other
important work. Um,
and here,
uh,
it seems to me that her reflections in
some ways give us a sideways exit from
the predicaments that I've been talking
about. The problem of, of essential ism,
the problem of the identity queue
because what Morrison wants to say,
and I think she borrows a
here particularly from the
famous discussion of the
master slave dialectic in
Hegel's phenomenology of mine.
What Morrison wants to
say is that it's not,
is that identity isn't so much
a question of what something is,
but rather a question of what it is not.
She says it's not that we should be so
much preoccupied with what it is to be
black,
but rather as we think
about the way in which, uh,
being black is inscribed
within the white tradition.
As we think about that,
we need to think about
what white is not at about.
In other words, as she says
repeatedly about black as absence,
as negation, as negativity. And that we,
and we have to understand the absolute,
and this is where,
this is where she drives her argument
from the master slave dialectic, uh,
the absolute necessity in the construction
of white identity for there to be as
an absence,
as a lack a over against white identity,
the existence of the African American.
And more particularly for the better part
of the American cultural tradition of
the slave. Uh, let me quote then, uh,
from her essay on page 1795,
the left hand column where she says,
construction of black,
this is third of the way down construction
of blackness and enslavement could be
found not only the,
not in that construction of blackness
and enslavement could be found not only
the, not free, but also the
projection of the not me.
The result was a playground
for the imagination.
What rose up out of collective needs
to la internal fears and rationalize
external exploitation
was an African Islam,
a fabricated brew of darkness,
otherness,
alarm and desire that
is uniquely American.
And then she points out that although
her subject is the American tradition,
there also exist to European Africanism
with its counterpart in its own colonial
literature. Um, to reinforce this,
she takes a remarkable example,
which must've reminded you those,
those of you who know Faulkner of
Thomas Satanic at least reminded,
reminded you in some ways of Thomas
Sut pen of this character Dunbar,
uh, who actually rose up not
so much out of the swamp.
Has Out of the Scottish enlightenment
and came to the United States.
And according to Bernard Bailyn,
the historian from whom she
takes this information, um, uh,
who became a transformed character.
Um,
I won't quote to the long passage from
Baylands tax too, which makes what, uh,
Morrison wants to take from it clear,
but rather from what Morrison
summarizes of it. Uh,
on page 1796,
the top of the right hand column I take
says Morrison William Dunbar to be a
succinct portrait of the process by which
the American as new white and male was
constituted.
It is a formation that has
several attractive consequences,
all of which are referred to in Balan
summation of Dunbar's character and
located in how Dunbar fields
within himself a power,
a sense of freedom he
had not known before.
This is uncannily parallel,
by the way, to the rational,
the rationalization for
slaves in Greek culture.
The way the Greeks always said that
the reason they had slaves with so they
could be free, in other words, uh,
so that the home or ruling
population could, was liberated. Uh,
in the case of the Greeks from a
performing the daily necessities of,
uh, that our life sustaining and
keep us going. Uh, in other words,
to be free,
uh,
according to the citizen of the Greek
Polis is to be free from work. Now,
in a certain way,
this is still a rationalization
that Toni Morrison sees in,
uh,
the American slave owning tradition.
But it's not so much in the case of
this Dunbar of freedom from work.
It's,
it's the case of a more broad
and insidious idea of freedom,
freedom from responsibility,
freedom from the need, uh,
to acknowledge otherness as human
freedom and other words from the sorts of
confront constraint imposed by all world
civility in Scotland and in London,
uh, freedom on this
frontier, in this wilderness,
in this swamp,
simply to be whatever one wants to be.
And that freedom is a achieved
on the backs of the black slave.
It is, uh, in some ways, similar,
as I say, to the rationalization,
rationalization for
first slavery in grace.
But it is in a way more insidious,
uh,
and certainly more,
in the terms that Morrison's giving it
to us and more dialectical that is to say
it is that the question whether a
person could become white without the
availability of a black
absence of a, of, of that,
which a of that which can be
oppressed like a kind of like,
like it like a kind of a spring,
uh, for the Jack in the box,
which allows the White Jack in the
box to leap out of the box, uh,
because of that, which is suppressed
down below all of that. Uh,
as part of Toni Morrison's concern at,
at colors her, well,
certainly controversial, uh,
reading of huckleberry Finn, which
nevertheless it seems to me, uh, has,
uh, a quite profound interest. Now, uh,
my own first instinct when when people
single out huckleberry Finn as to wince
away because, uh, it's an
extraordinary novel. Um,
the controversy about it, uh, in the
school districts which made it, um,
banished book, uh, had mainly
to do with the n word, uh,
to which we'll return the question
who has the right to use the n word,
which is not an easy question
to answer as we'll see. Um,
but that controversy while it had a,
an authentic basis,
uh,
seeing was nevertheless,
certainly in literary terms and in terms
of the imagination, uh, perhaps, um,
perhaps rather limited.
Uh,
Morrison gives rise to another equally
and intensely critical way of thinking
about huckleberry Finn.
She argues that to liberate gym,
which of course is the tremendous
failure at the end of the novel,
a failure of imagination
on the part of Tom Sawyer,
a failure of a will or independence of
mind on the part of huck himself that the
failure to liberate gym, which would
have been the easiest thing in the world.
All they had to do was point,
was point out.
The right fork in the river is a,
is an absolute necessity for the ongoing
self definition of whiteness as it's
available both to hop to Tom and to huck.
And after all,
by implication to mark Twain himself,
he couldn't figure out how to
end the novel. He wrote it, uh,
it lay on his desk for a long time because
he just couldn't figure out what to
do with it. And he finally comes
up with this as we all agree,
a polling ending.
Toni Morrison says it's the
only of ending available.
It's the only ending available
because in ways that the, uh, as she,
as she sees it
sentimentality of the novel,
the sentimentality of the relationship
between hock and, uh, uh, Jim,
which is so strong that it caused another
critic named Leslie Fiedler to talk
about, uh, uh, um, homoerotic
relation between them. The, the,
the title of Fiedler's famous essay
has come up on Duran huck honey. Uh,
you know, with all w w w with
all that in the background, uh,
Toni Morrison says,
the basic structure of consciousness
in Twain's novel is obscured a basic
structure,
which makes it absolutely
imperative that Jim not be free.
If Jim has freed,
then there is no other
over against twitch.
Whiteness can define itself.
That's the way in which she makes
use of the general argument about the
traditions of American
literature and culture, uh,
in applying it to huckleberry
Finn. All right, let's go back to,
uh, skip gates. Oh, sorry.
Henry Louis Gates. Sorry. Wait.
And another person who was at
Yale and whom I knew very well.
I actually had little bit to do with the
origin of the notion of the signifying
monkey. Uh, I'll come back to that later.
Barbara Johnson also now at Harvard. Um,
and I, uh, had a lot of conversations
with skip at that period, uh,
about this. And so it's not that
I feel proprietary, it skips idea.
Um, but I, you know, I was in on
that. Um, and so, uh, and, and so,
um, I, it's not just
name dropping. I get to,
I get to call him by what his friends
caught. So, so in any case it is, however,
I'll try to remember to say
Henry Louis Gates. Um, and, uh,
in any case to return to him.
Um,
I want to talk a little bit about
simply in the before moving on to this,
to this crucial central issue.
I want to talk a little bit, uh,
simply about his understanding
and the other staff,
the understanding of other African
American tradition, a critics,
both of the critical tradition
and of the literary tradition.
First of all,
the grasp of the critical tradition
as basically a two step or two part
progression is something that he shares
with Elaine Showalter from last time.
You remember, Joe Walters says
that the important movement of,
um,
of feminists interventions in literary
criticism begins with the moment that she
calls feminists. That is to say
the moment of Kate Millet, uh,
and other authors who talk
about the degradation, uh,
and unfair treatment
of women in male books.
And then what Showalter perverse
and suppose as to have super,
to have to have, uh, uh,
uh, uh, supervened, uh,
and to have become more important
gyno critical, uh, criticism,
which as women's appropriation of
literary traditions for themselves,
uh, the, uh,
the archival work that makes
the Canon of women's literature,
not just, uh, leaping from
great name to great name,
but an actual unfolding and continuous
development from decade to decade as show
Walter puts it. Um, now
gates on page 1896, uh,
the right hand margin sees
it in much the same way, uh,
for the development of African American.
Because you can do two things.
Basically says gates. He doesn't put
them chronologically, but you could see,
you could,
you could map onto what he's saying here,
the same chronological sequence.
He says what I mean by citing these to
overwork terms he's talking about the
other in particular,
uh, is precisely this.
How blacks are figures in literature.
That is to say how they're represented
in literature demeaningly even perhaps
terrifically,
how blacks are figured in literature
and also how blacks figure as it were,
literature of their own making.
You can see, in other words,
the same movement and his thinking
about these issues now as show,
alter argued the question or the
literary tradition is more complicated.
It has more steps. The, in other words,
the powers of self expression available
to women from the beginning of their,
uh, creative expression, um,
pass through more than just two stages.
And the same thing is true of
African American literature.
Now I think that,
uh,
Gates simply takes for granted
as an implicit premise. Uh,
the work that was done the
year before he published, uh,
this essay in critical inquiry,
uh,
by another colleague of ours here at
Yale who died tragically not too long
thereafter named Michael Cook,
who in 1984 wrote a book called African
American Literature in the 20th century.
The achievement of intimacy
and cook argued in his book
that the history of Afro
African American literature passes
essentially through four stages.
It begins with what Cook
Calls Self veiling, uh,
the period in other words in which
people attempting for the first time, uh,
uh, two, right. And of course, gates
talks about the way in which, uh,
writing is really writing
oneself into the human community.
Uh,
for black people,
the people who first attempted
to write used white models,
Phillis Wheatley, the poet whom
gates talks about a remarkable poet.
And a very interesting one,
nevertheless wrote, uh,
in the manner of Alexander Pope.
So much so that a great deal of
her work is almost impossible,
which is of course, as
you know, point of praise,
almost impossible to distinguish
from that of Alice Alexander Pope.
So she is an instance of
the first phase, uh, which,
which cook calls self veiling.
Second Phase, which cook calls.
Solitude involves continuing
to use white models,
a white pro style, uh, uh,
way of, uh, of narrating,
um, which is obviously derived from, uh,
white teachers and white models,
but which nevertheless involves as its
central theme self-definition here.
Uh, you might want to
think of Douglas, uh,
and of slave narratives in
general where the emphasis is,
where the emphasis is on
being taught by white people,
but nevertheless, the tension
which never w which exists, uh,
and which founds,
uh,
and governs the possibility of
self liberation and self freedom.
In other words, uh, the slave
narrative, uh, as an ongoing form,
uh, partakes of, uh,
this second phase in the development
of African American literature is cook
understands it. Thirdly, there's
what cook calls kinship, uh,
a literature in which African
Americans reach out to each other,
identify themselves as a community and
not as individuals struggling to be free,
but rather as a community.
And Cook identifies this phase with
the experimentation with dialect,
uh, and uh, the A and a way of, of, of,
of, of narrating and poets
[inaudible], uh, which is which, which,
which involves a self
conscious, uh, uh, uh,
insistence on verbal and
linguistic difference.
You can think of many of the poems,
for example,
of Langston Hughes in this regard and
have a great deal else that goes on in the
Harlem Renaissance. So that's the third
phase kinship. And then the last phase,
and what I'm going to want to say is that
gates doesn't think we've reached this.
Uh,
in other words,
the point of disagreement between Cook
and Gates is precisely about this.
The last phase which cook calls intimacy
is the freedom to expropriate any and
all models, not in other words, to
insist necessarily on one's own,
uh, uh, on, on one's own
creative paradigms, uh,
as a racial tradition,
uh,
to expropriate anything that comes
ready to hand Ellison's invisible man,
for example, as a masterpiece
of high modernism. Uh, it, it,
it takes freely,
in other words,
from whatever traditions
si come, come to hand, uh,
and are most readily available for the
kind of work that Ellison wants to do.
A cook identifies this perhaps rather
optimistically with what he calls
intimacy.
In other words,
a merger of finally achieved
merger of traditions such that,
and this is plainly the ideal
of Virginia Wolfe as well,
such then one such that one no longer
has to write as a spokesperson.
One no longer needs to be concerned,
uh, for Thema [inaudible].
Uh,
the kinds of identity that out of which
one writing one's writing has arisen.
One can write just anything one
wants to, uh, in other words, a,
the Utopian vision of no matter who I am,
uh,
having access to absolutely
any forms, uh, and themes,
uh, I care to work with. That
is the vision of Michael Cook,
which gates,
um,
I think unfortunately rightly feels
that we haven't quite arrived at.
And that's why,
um,
I deliberately use the word expropriate
in talking about Cook's fourth phase.
If I use models other than models
made available by my own tradition,
I'm not just kind of
pulling them out of the air.
I'm using them with a calculated purpose.
I always have something in mind and
choosing the model that I choose.
Uh, we're, we're not, you know, we're,
we're not really quite at intimacy
because self definition is still at issue.
You can talk about the high modernism
of the invisible man, all you like.
But think of what the
invisible man is a bout.
The invisible man is still about what it
means to be black. You know, what is it?
I said, what is passing? Uh,
what does it, what does it mean?
In other words, uh, to have, um,
this racial identity so
that, yeah, traditions, uh,
US manners styles have been,
uh, have been expropriated,
but at the same time,
the business of writing avid as an African
American continues and it is as much
after all a question of self definition,
uh,
as it has been hither too. So
that as, as Gates sees it, uh,
is, is, continues to be the
issue. We use other models.
We need to make them our own.
Otherwise we're just colonized by them.
And after all,
we're back in phase one.
Right?
We're back in self
veiling because after all,
Phillis Wheatley used other models.
Phyllis,
Phyllis Wheatley actually aspire to
the idea that she was just deport.
She could write about anything.
She wanted to write about the tears of
Nivea and the painting by Richard Wilson,
whatever it might be. She could
write about it. Uh, because, um,
she was just a poet.
That was her great aspiration was to be,
was to be received,
not as, uh, you know,
that amazing thing. Uh,
a young black slave woman who could write,
she wasn't interested in that. She wanted
to be a poet. And so in a certain sense,
you can see the problem
if intimacy as achieved in
the fourth pays fourth phase,
well then that's finally
just the realization of what
Phyllis Wheatley wanted in
the first phase. And,
uh, we have to admit, uh,
for all of the complicated reasons
that these critics go into,
that this is not a moment which can
be said yet to have been achieved.
Okay. Now this brings us
to gates is key concept.
What does it mean and what is the
advantage of x two to expropriate,
uh, uh, other people's
traditions? Eh, more particularly,
uh, the white tradition. And here, uh,
gates is after all thinking
primarily about criticism.
How can we do theory and criticism
in the White Man's language?
How can we appropriate
expropriate for ourselves?
The white man's language and the
necessity of bending language to one's own
purposes is what is emphasized in the
remarkable epigraph on page 1891 that
gates takes from [inaudible]. Uh, this is,
it seems to me as central a
passage in Bakhtin by the way,
as anything that we studied when
we were actually reading Bactine.
And I'd like you to make note of it,
uh,
because I think it really can
eliminate a great deal, uh,
that's going on in Bactine that we didn't,
uh,
perhaps fully articulate at the time.
This is what buck teen says,
language for the individual consciousness
lies on the borderline between oneself
and the other.
The word in language is half someone
else's to become one's own only when it
becomes one's own.
Only when the speaker populates
it with his own intention,
his own accent.
And you can,
you can hear gates wanting to
emphasize that word, accent,
his own accent when he
appropriates the word,
adapting it to his own semantic
and expressive intention.
Prior to this moment of appropriation,
the word does not exist in a
neutral and impersonal language.
It is not after all out of a dictionary
that the speaker gets his words.
You know how true,
how true it is.
Not after all out of a dictionary
that the speaker gets his words,
but rather it exists in
other people's mouths,
in other people's contexts,
serving other people's intentions.
It is from there that one must take
the word and make it one's own.
Now actually, during the course
of his essay, uh, uh, uh,
gates echoes the sentiment of
Bactine by quoting dairy. Dot.
At the very top of the right hand
column on page 1901 where he says,
uh,
we must master as Derrida wrote,
how to speak the other's language
without renouncing our own.
Now how do you do this?
What does,
how do you set about taking
the language you are given?
And this isn't of course, just a question
of the difference between the races.
It's a question of all of us in relation
to each other. As black teen, uh,
says in what you have already read,
most of the time we're speaking
other people's languages, um, are,
it is rare indeed that we can say,
uh,
feeling very much like creative writers
when we do so that we've somehow
wrenched other people's language
out of its conventional usages.
And made it our own,
slightly rewritten it so
that it is truly our own.
So, uh, more broadly speaking,
this is the challenge that faces,
uh,
a theoretical tradition or a
theoretical enterprise I should say.
That doesn't want to be just derivative,
uh,
from what other folks have already said.
The word,
the concept that gates brings to bear on
this because after all he recognizes as
does show Walter to that the notion of
the sign is probably the cornerstone of
white male literary theory.
They are agonizes that in order
to perform this x procreative act,
he's got to do something
with the notion of the sign.
And so he talks about the way in
which one can signify on something.
He introduces it very
quietly, uh, on page 1900,
uh,
the right hand column just seemingly in
passing since we're top of near the top
of the right hand column.
Since writing according to Hume,
was the ultimate sign of difference
between animal and human.
These writers implicitly we're signifying
upon the figure of the chain itself.
Notice the accent.
You don't necessarily pronounce the GE,
they were signifying on the chain.
And of course the great chain of being,
which is hierarchical
is very different from the vertical
chain of the chain gang, isn't it?
It's very difficult.
It's very different from the
chain that holds slaves together.
That's part of what it means
to signify on something.
The signifier, at least allegedly,
the signifier in the white male,
uh,
theoretical tradition is just a kind
of placeholder in a play of linguistic
differences.
The question of the underlying
sociological and cultural
basis of this play and
or the way in which this play take
shape isn't taken into account again,
allegedly because well,
you know,
in ways that you can probably grasp
from what we've said all along,
this is slightly to oversimplify, but
this is the position taken up. Uh,
and in any case,
you therefore need to take the
signifier and signify on it. Well,
what is it to signify on something?
This is an expression that gates
takes from the trickster tradition,
the tradition of African storytelling
in which the weaker is also the smarter
and the monkey or a non-key the spiders.
Some of you may remember the songs of
Rafi from your childhood. About a non-key,
the spider and which the
monkey or the spider tricks,
the big bad guys, the elephant, the lion,
all the bad guys get tricked
because they're stupider.
And the Little Guy,
uh,
is always able to signify on them,
to trick them,
to lie to them without their
realizing what's going on.
And this way of talking about signifying
is very much in the tradition of
African American folklore
and is, and, and,
and his first comes to
public consciousness, uh,
in a song by the Scott Singer, Oscar
Brown, Jr written by Oscar Brown,
Jr called the signifying monkey. If
I could sing, I would sing it to you.
Uh, fortunately I can't sing.
Uh, but you can, it, it, it,
it became extremely popular and was
picked up by various instrumental jazz
groups, uh, and was,
and was a staple in the jazz
tradition of the fifties and sixties.
Uh, in any case, uh,
Oscar Brown jr his notion of
the signifying monkey, uh,
is where gates takes his essays
title from a and which is where,
uh, also, um, uh, he
gets this idea of, uh,
taking somebody else's
discourse out of its context,
uh,
and insisting on bending it into
an African American context.
In other words,
a context which is one's own and
not just the context one is given.
Now, uh, the other
example of signifying on,
uh, that gates gives as the
culminating example of, uh, of,
of, uh, the color purple, uh,
and the conversation about getting the
men, getting the man out of your eye,
uh, which, uh,
is a way of taking back a problem that
exists even within the African American
tradition as gates has been pointing
out Wheatley and later Rebecca Cox, uh,
or rather Rebecca Jackson,
um, take their models, uh,
of education and self development from
white male figures who have taught them
how to read. And in each case, of course,
this is pernicious because the
existence of the white male figure is,
um, is, uh, very much
still in the, in your eye.
You got to get the man out of your eye,
at least according to the dialogue gates
quotes from the color purple. Well,
the interesting thing there is that in
a way the issue of feminist criticism
comes back to haunt gates.
His argument,
because plainly shook doesn't just mean
the white man when she says the man.
A big issue in the color purple of course,
is the emergence of a possible feminism,
uh,
from, uh, social constructions
that aren't just defined by race.
So that when Gates says, you know, the
man, which all of us recognize, uh,
as shorthand for the white man,
uh,
can be signified on by an African
American tradition making it a term of
opprobrium, right? Get
the man out of your eye.
At the same time, it can be signified
on by the feminist tradition,
making it a term of opprobrium,
not in a completely different way,
but in an overlapping and
partially different way. Uh,
and gates in emphasizing the one as
opposed to the other is perhaps tilting
again, uh, toward a certain imbalance.
Now finally, I want to take
up, uh, the example, uh,
the most controversial
example in his essay one, uh,
which is a source of outrage
for most readers. Uh,
at the bottom of page 1893
in the left hand column,
he's been talking about the new, he's been
talking about the new agrarian moment,
uh, out of which there emerged a number
of figures associated with the new
criticism, uh, including
Robert Penn Warren,
who very early on repudiated the
new Agrarians, uh, and became,
um, uh, a politically progressive
figure in his own writing. You've,
many of you have probably
read all the king's men, uh,
certainly in his poetry as
well, but who was a, an Avatar,
a central figure in the,
in the development of the
thinking of the new criticism,
which we have briefly studied.
Now,
Warren wrote a poem called
Pondi Woods, which, uh,
is quoted completely out of
context by Sterling Brown, uh,
uh, and unfairly out of
context, uh, in the passage,
which I'm not going to read because I
don't think I have the right to speak the
n word. Uh, and so, uh, I'll
just have you look at it.
Um, but then, and I'll come back
to that in a minute. Um, and then,
uh, uh, the sterling Brown's response, uh,
is also recorded there, uh, for you. Well,
the problem is this for this from the
standpoint of anybody who's actually read
the poem,
but remember in,
in some ways it's a problem raised by a
new critical perspective. And I'll show,
and I'll explain what I mean in a minute.
That expression is spoken by
a buzzard or vulture from,
I forget whether it's
Tennessee or Kentucky.
They episode takes place
in northern Louisiana, uh,
and the buzzard is sitting expectedly on
a tree waiting for a fugitive slave who
has been chased into the swamp
by his white pursuers to die.
And the vulture is sitting
there. Well, if it could,
it would be rubbing his hands with
glee waiting for this to take place.
And it's the vulture that says
it and the poem, nothing to do.
In other words,
as we say with the author of the poem,
Warren,
who is writing a completely sympathetic
evocation of what it's like to be a
fugitive slave in this state of terrible,
uh,
and overwhelmed panic.
And so it seems completely
unfair and it is, I think,
unfair as sterling brown took it up and
as gates then perpetuates the idea in
his own reference. The one
thing I would add, however,
is that it's a new critical idea that
we invoke to say that it's unfair.
It's the new criticism of which
robbery in which Robert War.
Penn Warren was a participant that tells
us we shouldn't confuse speakers in
poems with authors.
In other words,
and author,
as someone according to Lou criticism,
who's dispassionate and who
introduces dramatic voices,
even in lyric poems,
voices with which we are
merely confusing ourselves. Uh,
if we associate them, uh,
with, uh, with an author.
Now this is, uh, something that we
just for granted when we read poems,
all poems for us are to some
degree dramatic monologues
on the model of Browning
and others, uh, in the 19th
century. We read them that
way now. But it is, as I say,
a new critical idea.
And it comes back to the question,
who has the right to use the n word?
It's a frequently,
it's a frequent sort of term
used on the street as you know,
and African American culture used
almost with a certain fondness, uh,
as a form of mutual greeting.
But at the same time,
it is a term that continues rigorously
to be rejected as available to anyone
other than someone who
belongs within this community.
And so that issue lingers.
It's an issue that Warren,
because of course he wrote long before,
uh,
this sort of controversy began
to arise around the word. Uh,
the controversy really boiled over
precisely at the time of the banning of
huckleberry Finn from public
schools. Uh, uh, and so, uh,
there's a kind of innocence perhaps,
uh, in Warren's use of the word.
But nevertheless, uh, in
the critical tradition,
it's a question who has
the right to use it?
And this gives rise perhaps to the
suggestion of a certain insularity in the
thinking of the new criticism.
Take the fee,
let let use any model you like.
The model of the Floridian unconscious,
the model of the political unconscious.
In other words,
we've been reading a lot in this course
about are never quite saying what we
mean to say of our never quite being
fully in control of our discourse because
it bubbles up from the
unconscious right now,
if you take a model like this,
even though it's a nasty buzzard from
Kentucky that's saying what gates quotes.
Nevertheless,
there is an author and it has bubbled
up from the unconscious of that. Well,
what are you going to do with that?
There's a kind of impasse there.
We feel distinctly and vividly and
even bitterly because I love Warren.
I love Ponti Woods and I also
am something of a new critic,
so we feel a bitterness
about the expropriation,
the signifying on what
Warren says in this fashion,
but at the same time we have entertained
these ideas of a subliminal author,
not an authority,
but an author welling up from below.
And if that's the case,
if that's the case,
then we have to worry a little bit about
how an expression like that got into
the poem afterwards, after all. Um,
and so that to,
I call it a lingering problem because it
strikes me as one of those moments when
probably would have been better if gates,
uh, hadn't followed sterling Brown.
Uh, one of those moments
when there is a kind of, uh,
overkill in the zeal of argumentation,
uh,
but which at the same time,
we can't absolutely dismiss out of hand
for the variety of reasons that I've
mentioned. Okay. I'll
leave it like at there,
and we'll return to many of these issues
in a new vocabulary and in new forms.
When we read the examples of postcolonial
criticism on Thursday that you've been
assigned.